so i'm gonna pull up the story right
here this is from cnn biden admin eyes a
potentially stark shift in messaging
around ending the pandemic so tomorrow
we're supposed to get a statement from
joe biden about what they're gonna do
but his his message was clear they say
quote for the unvaccinated we are
looking at a winter of severe illness
and death for the unvaccinated he said
it twice i guess for themselves their
families and the hospitals they will
soon overwhelm but there's good news if
you're vaccinated and you have your
booster shot you're protected from
severe illness and death now i don't
want to play any silly games dragging
joe uh joe biden this is not his
administration well i guess they say you
know this is biden's you know address of
the american people
saying that many people were like yo
it's just before christmas and you're
going to be like you're going to face
death and illness and everything but
people on the left are going to be like
he's just warning people as he should so
i'm not going to i'm not going to play
games and be like ah we don't like biden
so we criticize every single thing he
says i will tell you you will not
convince anyone that
you know when biden said if you're
vaccinated and you have your booster
shot you're protected from severe
illness and death i want to make two
very important points i'm not a
scientist i can't tell you i'll make
three actually i can't tell you anything
about the research being done on this
stuff i got no idea you make sure you
talk to a doctor you know and trust get
a second opinion i can tell you that i
was interacting with someone on twitter
who said just got my third shot and then
i said are you gonna get your booster
and this guy responds i just said i got
my third shot i said no no i meant the
fourth shot because but i'm not trying
to be a dick like literally several
leftist publications have already said a
full vaccine dose is three shots and he
said it's a stupid conversation because
every year we get a flu shot and no one
asks you if it's your eight if it's your
18th my response to that is the flu
shots as i understand it are different
meaning every year they say here's the
dominant strain here's the vaccine for
this strain and a few others it might
not stop his other strains the covet
vaccine is one vaccine developed
specifically for the alpha strain and
now we're getting we're we're looking
for data on whether or not it will stop
omnicron as joby likes to call it or any
other variant and if that's the case
joe biden is not doing anything by
saying this when you have this story
elizabeth warren vaxxed and vaccinated
and boosted tests positive for coven
corey booker positive for chronovirus
both elizabeth warren and cory booker
are vaccinated and boosted and then we
have jim cramer who of cnbc who said
he said that the military should
forcefully vaccinate people and he
posted a positive test now i'm not going
to tell you what or why that is i'll
tell you my theory on exactly what this
is i believe is it is infinitely more
likely
it infinitely likely or i should say
just simple put it simply
i believe all these people lied about
getting vaccinated whoa
okay
i i mean like look there's a photo of
elizabeth warren and they're putting a
needle in her arm yeah i think you've
got two potentials
the vaccine isn't working on the
variance the efficacy has waned to the
point where covid cases in new york are
breaking records
or
these specific politicians and high
profile individuals who go on tv and
virtue signal about the vaccine never
got it someone's laying here yeah and it
it's funny because it's a lose lose
either way yeah
just just after this point as well like
okay
what's the the goal here because is it
control is it to like say okay you know
what do what they say or not and if
that's the case then when does it stop
because this is just this mouth it's
like okay vaccine or you might die or
maybe it could be like okay if we're in
power you don't do what i say you'll die
regardless so just like to me it's more
like control yeah there's a lot of
things going on on right now that are
totally breaking the official narrative
of what's going on here and that white
house memo was released by their chief
of staff not by joe biden but i mean it
sounded more threatening than
warning but their response to everything
happening is get boosted media get
boosted as they're running
sensationalistic fear-mongering articles
but of course as you mentioned tim cory
booker hunter walker elizabeth warren
the governor of maryland jim cramer most
cnn and buzzfeed employees all triple
vaxxed with boosters all of them
recently came down with this new
coven 19
sickness like what's going on cnn shut
their offices down
and cnn fired employees who were
unvaccinated so all of the employees at
cnn were vaccinated hold on hold on
boosted well done okay
i'm not a scientist
i can't say the vaccines work or don't
work clearly the only thing that makes
sense if that's true is that every
single one of these high-profile
democrats celebrities and every employee
at cnn faked getting the vaccine i'll
say this real quick here
i'll just say this and then the people
can think what they want the vaccine i
remember rolled out right around about a
year ago right the first the first time
they're like listen just take this shot
you'll be good and then next thing you
know we're here a year later now we're
up to three shots and the people that
take the shots allegedly are still
getting the virus still passing the
virus basically doing all the things
that the vaccine was developed to keep
you from doing and
it's crazy it's like
what's how many more vaccines are they
going to make how many more do you have
to take it i think i think there's
actually maybe a very very simple
explanation
well yeah i am being a bit facetious
when i say obviously like one of those
but i think i think coverts become
endemic
it's going to be a yearly thing which
has been stated by many many people yeah
and the alpha vaccine that they got
under eua is slowly becoming not the
appropriate vaccine for whatever is you
know emerging now because the vir the
virus spreads i think i think the issue
is if the cdc comes out and just finally
says covet has become endemic it's never
going away
then the the establishment loses their
power all of a sudden people are going
to be like i guess i got to live my life
then but if they maintain that we're in
a pandemic it'll never go away then they
will keep being able to force people
they will control people and i gotta say
i really don't think
i i that that the goal of the vaccine
mandates is vaccines i think it's social
credit systems
you're absolutely right and from a
logical point of view from a medical
point of view if you really wanted to
help people now you would be dealing
with early treatment you would be
dealing with accepting the risk here uh
helping the vulnerable but what's
happening is they're still on this crazy
insane journey to prevent people from
getting sick how why are you doing this
when clearly you have failed and the
more you do the more people get infected
and hurt here so from a logical point of
view this doesn't add up to helping
australia new zealand clarify though i
don't know if it's more people are
getting it but certainly people are
still getting it i think the numbers
have went up especially under the bible
administration
what i mean yeah i just don't want us to
get to the point of australia and new
zealand they can't even leave you know a
mile and a half two miles of their place
their ability to get food is controlled
it's crazy let me let me tell you i'll
spin you a little tail so
i posted
hey look you know australia built these
quarantine camps
then i said what's going to happen is
there's going to be a protest they're
going to claim it was a super spreader
event they got to put these people in
quarantine i got called a conspiracy
theory for that then they started taking
people and putting them in these
quarantine camps at first i said it was
an international arrival bungalow now
it's the police come to your house and
without due process take you to the
camps here's the best part i was talking
about the native america the i'm sorry
the indigenous in australia the native
australians yes and uh i said
the minister of uh the north the
northern territory said you no longer
have the five reasons to leave your home
that means you can only leave your home
now for emergency medical treatment and
i said that quite literally means you
can't leave your house to go and get
food yep
and then what happens is they pull up
and say come with us we're taking you to
the camp and then these people try
escaping three teenagers escaped what
happens the latest response from
quillette this you know psychotic
publication that claims to be about
freedom was that tim poole lied because
while they can't leave their homes to
get food they're not being deprived the
government is delivering morning meals
to them and i'm like i said you can't
leave your house even to get food and
they're like but he's implying people
are starving i don't care if the
government fires food out of a cannon
through your window i don't care if they
bring you a filet mignon with grilled
asparagus and all of the uh
accompaniments yeah if you can't leave
your house to choose to get food on your
own we have certainly crossed that
threshold exactly that's where we're
going absolutely and the netherlands has
locked down for for another month right
now and and germany's talking about
making uh vaccines mandatory for
everyone forcing them on everyone this
is the german health minister that said
immediate forced vaccinations for the
entire population this is absolutely
crazy
before we get into all that
related to the cnn article about them
closing their offices and working from
home i saw one of the best memes i have
ever seen in my life in relation related
to this story and it's the the guy with
the yellow jacket clasping his hands
behind the tree and it says lubin tubin
when he finds out that he gets to work
from home
and i have to say the creativity on the
internet is
he really likes working from home
i just want to add to that point well
this is my song a little bit bass but uh
it was never about helping people become
better it's about control and if you
think about it right when does it end it
paul whenever never will end however
look what's happening now control's
happening like you mentioned australia
other countries
at some point
what's the goal here and if you think
about this long term like this affecting
how we how we buy food how we how we use
money how we uh travel australians can't
even leave talk to each other how we
date how we interact with people it's
like a heavy
place and control now when once this
happens like what's the end goal my
thing is how do we stop it we can't so
what what can we do create our own
communities and maybe thrive that way
but there's nobody i disagree with you i
mean the governor of florida came out
and released a very strong statement
today saying we will not let anybody
lock you down take your jobs ruin your
business or close your schools i don't
care what biden says we're not going to
be following his mandates his decrees
which he's going to be announcing in a
few hours from now which is supposed to
be new restrictions on the american
people so people of florida don't have
to go through a lot of the bull crap
miami dade is a little see we live in
florida right my question is how long
and it's but the funny part is that yes
he's he's doing that right now but
pressure and you know every other state
doing it eventually you can only hold it
for so long and mine
well florida never kind of uh i mean
yeah we never we we never really closed
down yeah they never really closed out
but miami dade but you didn't close the
day
we definitely we closed and like miami
dade was the last county to open back up
now obviously the rest of florida you
know has their head on straight yeah but
miami-dade in general like we opened up
recently we just opened up a few months
ago you know fully so
yeah i mean it is what it is but no
florida definitely is it's a good state
to be right now compared to other places
hell us coming to here you know to the
dc airport and i'm just seeing like you
know people running around mass
everywhere i was like oh wow i'm seeing
this yeah you don't see this in florida
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you